welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and it's time to
travel to the five-star island of oc to
discuss
everything that you need to know about
the third day throughout this video
we're going to be going over the entire
show's plot
and it's ending so obviously there will
be heavy spoilers here
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the third day
okay so the third day experience is
actually cut up into three chapters that
cover several characters
as they try to get to the bottom of
what's happening on the mysterious
island of oc
the first is summer which follows sam
played by jude law
as he goes on a journey to discover the
truth about his son's disappearance
which just so happens to be tied to the
island itself
the second part which was actually
broadcast as a 12-hour live event on the
island
is called autumn and this followed sam
as he was subjected to his trials
the third which is called winter follows
sam's wife helen
played by naomi harris as she searches
for the answers to what happened to her
husband
now the inhabitants of oc believe that
it is actually the soul of the world
and that if things are amiss on the
island the rest of the planet will decay
thus they see themselves as protectors
and have sought out the descendants of a
man known as frederick nicholas
charrington
who we learned founded the island
charrington took up the mantle of father
and together with his followers they
performed celtic rituals
in order to stop the world from getting
sick charrington's grandson
who happens to be sam's grandfather
ended up fleeing oc
after he was disgusted by the
ritualistic sacrifices that were
performed
and this is when things started to go
awry sam's grandfather's brother took up
the mantle himself
but things just haven't been the same
now the inhabitants believe that the
direct offspring of charrington
must rule over them in order to keep the
world in balance
and thus they've sought out his
descendants initially they wanted to use
samsung nathan
and hired someone to kidnap him however
this ended up backfiring
and thus they pulled sam back to the
island so that he can return it to order
in the woods he comes across a girl
named epona who's attempting to end her
own life
and takes her back to oc which is when
he's pulled into the true plot
oc is only accessible by a causeway that
often floods
and i thought it was brilliant how there
was always this ticking clock in the
background
in which the characters had to get off
the island before the tide rolled in
the first three episodes of the season
pretty much chronicle this
and we follow sam as he discovers the
truth about his son and his role on oc
after discovering opponent's body and
learning that she sacrificed herself to
try and heal the island
he ascends to the position of father the
previous father ends his life in front
of him
during the finale which which was it was
a bit weird
wasn't it now anyway during his time on
the island sam sleeps with a duplicitous
woman known as jess
and she ends up becoming pregnant with
his child which we'll get into in just a
bit
he's also forced to do several trials as
part of the autumn season
and these include him digging his own
grave and proving to the natives that
he's the right person for the job
these take place after a minor time jump
and we get another one as we head into
winter
now helen angered that sam disappeared
without a trace and took 40 000 pounds
from the family
heads out to the island in order to
retrieve the money they're in debt over
their heads
and have no future if they're unable to
pay off what's owed
upon arriving on oc helen pretends that
she's only taking her daughters tallulah
and ellie out to celebrate the latter's
birthday
but slowly she unearths that something
isn't right
with the causeway closing helen manages
to find a place to stay
and amongst the martins she discovers
jess is about to give birth
but will die if not given proper medical
attention
helen helps out and when interacting
with the villagers
they lie to her about ever seeing sam
however she learns from one of the drunk
locals that he was there
and upon confronting the martins they
lie and say that sam disappeared from
her
in order to hide his infidelity helen
goes to leave the island
but just as they're vacating they spot
jess walking into the sea
they take her to a house on the seafront
which is where she gives birth to sam's
daughter jess names her opponent
and he goes to the original opponent's
father jason aware that the baby's life
is in danger
because there can only be one true
descendant on the island
now jess tells helen to go and get sam
and we end episode 5 with helen coming
face to face with her husband
whilst jess goes to attack tallulah
episode 6 picks up immediately after
this
with helen confronting sam on the dock
he says he stayed on the island because
he found nathan
however this is quickly shown to be a
ruse and the boy
is simply a distant relative helen tells
us more about the child
and that if he was truly alive he would
be 16 and not the child that we've been
seeing about oc
his race is also wrong and we learn that
sam has simply accepted this child as
his son
in order to mentally exonerate himself
from his grief
people believe what they want to believe
and will force things to fit a narrative
in order to avoid accepting the truth
and i think the series is chronicling
the lens that one will go to
in order to avoid grief and despair sam
has simply been searching for answers
and helen unveils all the theories and
accusations that he held in order to
find a reason to not force himself to
accept
that nathan's disappearance was his
fault this operatic grief
is all just a way of avoiding coming to
terms with things
and sam would rather remain in this
state than face real life
it turns out that sam was supposed to be
keeping an eye on him but instead he was
on the phone with the woman that he was
having an affair with
sam spent 23 minutes and 17 seconds
talking to her
and i actually think that this holds a
special meaning now in the bible
proverbs 23 17 read don't envy sinners
but always continue to fear the lord
which ties not only into sam
but also the island itself yes that's
that's probably a reach however
the idea of forgotten children is not
only mirrored in kale and jess
but also sam and nathan as well as helen
and her daughters
who she pretty much abandons on oc in
order to find
sam the fake nathan has clearly been
influenced by the evil of the island
from what we see in his pictures and we
discovered that it was actually the
islanders that were behind the real
nathan's death
now they were truthful when stating that
they were behind kidnapping him
however it did go far beyond that nathan
realized what was happening
and tried to escape which is when his
kidnapper killed him
the islanders didn't even hand over the
real nathan's body
and instead they sacrificed jason's son
and dumped nathan in the causeway to
cover up the crime
now the episode really ramps up towards
the end with the power struggle of both
sides of the island coming out into the
open
throughout the season we've learned that
there exists people who have faith in
sam
and others that see him as a false
prophet who's not fit to lead
sam is worried that ellie and lou have
been brought to the island
and two face the danger of the native's
wrath which is warranted as
ellie is now under the wing of jess
whilst lula has to hide from the locals
jess uses ellie to draw the opposing
islanders and helen out
and she calls a truce between the
community however she kills mrs martin
who was one of the main reasons behind
the uprising
they sedate her and then drown her that
should her body be discovered
she would be seen as having drowned
helen and sam are taken to the oyster
which is when lula rescues them and the
family spring into action
helen forces sam to come to terms with
the fact that he lost nathan
and he kills some of the islanders and
rescues ellie
sam gives helen the cash from the altar
but instead of leaving he remains behind
with his truth which is that nathan is
still alive
now the fake one does allude to a
private conversation that he and helen
had
which does hint at the boy perhaps being
the real character
however i think that this signifies the
brainwashing that goes on on the island
and how pretty much everyone has been
forced into a role in some way
in order to serve a purpose those that
are team sam
are very much willing to give in to his
fantasies and they even kept them up in
order to make sure he maintained his
position
i think that this is so ingrained into
everyone that even this young child
truly believes that he is nathan now the
other way that you can take it
is that the mysticism we've been seeing
on the island is correct
and that in some ways nathan is alive
through this distant relative
i do think though that the main
aesthetic of the show is about embracing
the truth in spite of all the pain that
will be caused
and that it's better to be hit with the
harshness of reality than to remain in a
blanket of comforting lies
nowhere is this more exemplified than in
helen's escape from the island at the
end
now she could easily remain behind on oc
and live this lie with sam
but instead she puts her children in a
boat ties the rope on it around herself
and swims out into the icy cold waters
in order to escape from oc
it's a harrowing scene that's agonizing
to watch but at some point she turns
around
and witnesses a vision of nathan sat on
the boat
now to me this symbolizes that she's not
only saved her children
but also the idea of the real nathan who
will live on in her memories
instead of the fake one which sam has
remained behind with
she uses this to fight on through the
water and makes the escape
that sam was once unable to sam shared a
similar journey to helen
and almost made it off the island
himself however
he was convinced to go back now this
shows the oppositions of grief
and how some will accept the
circumstances and move on
whilst others like sam will remain in
whatever lie they tell themselves
there are theories that state helen is
the true mother of the island
just as sam is the father but unlike him
she turns away from her destiny
and the pageantry that surrounds it this
is much like how sam's ancestor did
when he realized that life on oc would
subject him and his offspring to several
tragedies
and thus she makes the right decision
helen makes it to the shore
and and lula take their mother to a
nearby house
and we see that she's suffering from
hypothermia however they manage to warm
her
and helen holds on tightly to what she
thinks is nathan's shirt
however it's really the bag of money and
we realize that both she and sam have
been hit with the same disaster
but they've chosen to handle it
differently helen now has a way to buy
her and her family out of debt
while sam will forever be trapped in his
mind state
although we don't know what will happen
to the island we do know that sam
isn't taking things lying down and that
he's willing to kill for his position
there's also the possibility of the
police arriving at the island to
investigate all the deaths
and i think that one way or the other oc
will fall
now this is of course a pretty
nihilistic way to look at things
but we do end with the sun shining which
does have a hopeful message to it
and i think that sam's offspring at the
very least will be okay
even if he's not anyway that ends the
season
and the third day and i love how we had
this constant repetition of three cycles
in both the days and seasons i really
enjoyed what happened in the show
and i highly doubt that we'll get a
second entry but if you're watching this
video for for whatever reason
without seeing it then i do recommend
that you check it out
their day was a show that kept me
constantly guessing and i did have a lot
of fun with it
overall i think it was a bit of a slow
burn but it definitely deserves your
attention
and only six episodes you know it's not
going to take that long to watch
their day was great and now i'm not sure
if fully delivered in the end
i still did have a lot of fun and it
gets a 7.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the ending and the series as
a whole
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the lovecraft country
finale which is going to be linked at
the end
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october and the
set will be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat just
on the discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
you